>>> IN O POLITICS LEAD,
FLORIDA LAWMAKERS ARE BACK IN
TALLAHASSEE FOA SPECIAL
SESSION AFTER REPUBLICAN
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS VETOED.
HE INSTEAD PROPOSE AD NEW ONE
THAT WOULD SHIFT POWER IN NORTH
AND CENTRAL FLORIDA.
CNN'S DIANE GALLAGHER IS IN
TALLAHASSEE.
A SPECIAL SESSION JUST STARTED.
WHAT ARE DEMOCRATS SAYING ABOUT
DeSANTIS' MAP?
>> Reporter: WELL, THEIR CALLING
IT RACIST, AUTHORITARIAN,
UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND THAT'S JUST
WHAT I CAN SAY ON CAMERA HERE.
DEMOCRATS SAY THAT THIS PROPOSAL
FROM GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS WOULD
NOT ONLY ADD MORE REPUBLICAN
SEATS BUT IT WOULD DIMINISH
BLACK REPRESENTATION IN CONGRESS
FOR THE STATE OF FLORIDA.
THERE ARE CURRENTLY FIVE BLACK
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS FROM
FLORIDA.
FOUR OF THEM ARE DEMOCRATS.
THIS MA'AM PROPOSAL WOULD
ELIMINATE TWO OF THOSE SEATS.
REPRESENTATIVE VAL DEMINGS'
SEATS.
THE REASON IS HE WANTED A RACE
NEUTRAL MAP THAT HE FELT ADHERED
TO THE U.S. CONSTITUTION.
BUT DEMOCRATS HAVE THAT NOT ONLY
DO THEY FEEL THIS WOULD BE IN
VIOLATION OF THE VOTING RIGHTS
AGENT BUT ALSO IN VIOLATION OF
FLORIDA'S OWN STATE CONSTITUTION
WHICH MANDATES THE PROTECTION OF
THOSE MINORITY DISTRICTS.
JAKE, IT WILL LIKELY PASS OUT OF
THIS SPECIAL SESSION LATE THIS
WEEK.
AND THEN IT WILL LIKELY END UP
IN COURT.
>> AND DIEIAN, THERE IS ANOTHER
BIG STORY GOING ON IN
TALLAHASSEE.
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS IS CHANGING IT
TO INCLUDE A REVIEW OF WALT
DISNEY WORLD AND THE SPECIAL
STATUS THAT WALT DISNEYWORLD HAS
IN FLORIDA.
TELL US ABOUT THAT.
>> Reporter: THAT SPECIAL STATUS
A SPECIAL DISTRICT THAT
ESSENTIALLY ALLOWS THEM TO
OPERATE AS THEIR OWN GOVERNMENT
AROUND THE ORLANDO AREA THEME
PARK.
THIS ALL STEMS FROM THAT SO
CALLED DON'T SAY GAY BILL
EARLIER THIS YEAR THAT PREVENTS
TEACHERS IN SCHOOLS FROM TALKING
ABOUT GENDER IDENTITY AND SEXUAL
ORIENTATION.
DISNEY SPOKE OUT AFTERWARD.
AT THIS POINT, I SPOKE TO THE
BILL'S SPONSOR.
HE SAID THAT THIS WASN'T
NECESSARILY RETALIATION, BUT
THAT AFTER DISNEY DID THAT, AND
SAID THEY WOULD STOP DONATING IN
THE STATE OF FLORIDA, THAT THEY
STARTED LOOKING INTO THE
STATE'S, ONE OF THE LARGEST
ATTRACTIONS AND EMPLOYERS AND
THAT'S WHERE THIS CAME FROM.
>> I THINK HAD DISNEY NOT DONE
WHAT THEY HAD DONE, WE WOULDN'T
HAVE GONE AND TAKEN A LOOK AT
SPECIAL DISTRIBUTIONS AND
REALIZED WE HAD THIS ISSUE WITH
THESE PRE CONSTITUTION SPECIAL
DISTRICTS.
THAT WOULDN'T HAVE HAPPENED.
WHEN YOU ADDICTION BEE'S NEST,
SOMETIMES THINGS COME OUT.
AND THAT HAS ABSOLUTELY HAPPEN
HERE.
>> Reporter: DEMOCRATS SAY THAT
THIS PARTICULAR BILL SEEMS TO BE
IN DIRECT ONLY SIGNIFICANCE OF
EXISTING STATUTES, JAKE, THAT
WOULD ALLOW THE RESIDENTS OF
THAT SPECIAL DISTRICT TO HAVE TO
VOTE TO GET RID OF IT.
BUT IT DOES APPEAR THAT IT WILL
PASS OUT.
>> INTERESTING.
THANK YOU.
SO.
LET'S DISCUSS.
WE'LL START WITH YOU.
IS GOVERNOR DeSANTIS TAKING ON
DISNEY FOR THE RIGHT REASONS?
JUST BECAUSE THEY CRITICIZED THE
LEGISLATION?
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> I THINK POLITICIANS' MOTIVES
ARE ALWAYS MIXED, OR USUALLY
MIXED.
THE FUNNY THING ABOUT THIS IS
THAT DISNEY'S SPECIAL STATUS,
ITS CO-MINGLING OF POWER, HAS
HAD THESE GAD FLY CRITICS,
MOSTLY ON THE LEFT.
NOW IT IS PAUBL GOVERNOR, PRETTY
STRAYED FORWARD, POLITICAL MOTEL
VEGASES, WHO HAS IT --
MOTIVATIONS, WHO HAS IT IN HIS
TARGETS.
>> SO MAYBE NOT THE WORST THING
IN THE WORLD.
>> I THINK THERE'S A STRONG CASE
THAT THE PRIVILEGES DON'T MAKE
SENSE.
THIS HAS BEEN SOMETHING PEOPLE
HAVE JUST SECOND AS A FACT OF
LIFE IN FLORIDA POLITICS FOR
DECADES NOW.
NOW ALL OF A SUDDEN, BECAUSE OF
THE WAY THE POLITICS OF DeSANTIS
AND DISNEY HAVE PLAYED OUT, IT
IS UP FOR GRABS AGAIN.
>> BUT THEY'RE NOT LOOKING AT
WHERE THEY ARE GIVEN
GOVERNMENTAL POWER.
HOW IS THIS FOR IRONY?
AT THE VILLAGES, YOU'VE BEEN
THERE.
IT IS THE MOST GARGANTUAN
RETIREMENT COMMUNITY.
>> KEEP GOING.
>> THEY HAVE THE SAME TYPE OF
SPECIAL CORPORATE GOVERNMENTAL
POWER BUT THEY TEND TO BE VERY
CONSERVATIVE.
SO DeSANTIS ISN'T GOING AFTER
THEM.
SO IT IS A NOVEL THING, GOING
AFTER THE LARGEST EMPLOYER IN
YOUR STATE.
IN MY HOME STATE, IT COST HIS
OWN STATE 477 MILLION OF
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY.
IT IS A NEW REPUBLICAN STRATEGY
IS TO ATTACK THE ECONOMIC END
GINS OF THEIR STATES.
>> PEOPLE USED TO WANT
REPUBLICANS TO BE LESS
CORPORATE.
>> HEMENTS TALKED ABOUT TAKING
TWITTER TO TASK TO STOP ELON
MUSK FROM BUYING THE COMPANY.
IT IS THAT.
WHY FLORIDA WOULD HAVE ANYTHING
TO DO WITH THAT IS BEYOND ME.
BUT PERHAPS IT IS THE LARGER
GOAL FOR GOVERNOR DeSANTIS WHICH
COULD BE 2024, FURTHER DOWN THE
LINE, BUT IT SEEMS LIKE HE'S
HITTING ALL THESE CULTURAL
TOUCHSTONE ISSUES.
IT SEEMS TO BE PART OF A LARGER
AND MORE NATIONAL, LET'S SAY,
MESSAGE.
>> DO I SEE LOTS OF CONSERVATIVE
ACTIVISTS REALLY LIKING WHAT
THEY SEE OUT OF GOVERNOR
DeSANTIS.
>> THEY WOULD LIKE IT.
I DON'T SEE DISNEY ELICITING A
WHOLE LOT OF SYMPATHY.
JUST BECAUSE YOU CAN DOESN'T
MEAN YOU SHOULD.
AND IN GOVERNOR DeSANTIS' CASE,
NOT ONLY ON THIS ISSUE BUT THE
REDISTRICTING.
I REBEL LASTIER WHEN CONGRESSMAN
JAMES COMBER OF KENTUCKY, THEY
WERE TALKING ABOUT CHEWING UP
LOUISVILLE.
WHICH IS A VERY LIBERAL
DISTRICT.
AND HE SAID, DON'T GET CUTE.
BECAUSE THESE THINGS CAN END UP
IN RT.
COULD IT LOOKS LIKE GOVERNOR
DeSANTIS IS NOT ALL THAT WORRIED
ABOUT THE POTENTIAL FOR THIS
ENDING UP IN COURT BUT IT COULD
HAVE OTHER IMPACTS.
COULD IT POSSIBLYIZE THE BLACK
ELECTORATE IN FLORIDA WHO FEEL
PUT OFF BY THIS AND FEEL AS
THOUGH THEY ARE GOING TO END UP
WITHOUT ACCURATE REFLECTIVE
REPRESENTATION.
>> RIGHT.
THERE ARE TWO BLACK DISTRICTS
THAT HE'S KEEPING.
HE'S GETTING RID OF TWO OTHER
AND THEN A REPUBLICAN AFRICAN
AMERICAN, TOO.
IT'S NOT LIKE HE'S GETTING ALL
OF THEM BUT HE IS TALKING ABOUT
GETTING RID OF TWO OF THEM.
>> AND HE FEELS AS IF IF THERE
ARE COURT CHALLENGES, THE
SUPREME COURT IN FLORIDA WILL
SUPPORT HIM IN THIS DECISION.
>> OR THE FEDERAL COURTS TOO.
HE'S MAKING A STAND THAT FEDERAL
LAW TRUMPS STATE LAW WHEN IT
COMES TO THESE STATE ISSUES.
>> BUT POLITICALLY, IT DOESN'T
COME WITHOUT ANY RISKS.
>> RIGHT.
THE BACK LASH.
IN TERMS OF REDISTRICTING, YOU
SEE IT ALL OVER THE MAP.
REPUBLICANS OR DEMOCRATS.
PEOPLE GETTING SUPER AGGRESSIVE.
NOBODY EVEN TRYING TO HIDE IT
ANYMORE.
AM I WRONG?
>> NO.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
A DEMOCRATIC CONTROLLED STATE
LOOKS LIKE IT WILL BE
EXTRAORDINARILY BEEN OFFICIAL.
>> ILLINOIS GOT RID OF ADAM
KINSINGER'S SEAT.
>> AND VERY OFTEN THEY'LL DO
THAT BECAUSE HE'S RETIRING.
>> HE'S RETIRING BECAUSE TRUMP
HATES HIM.
>> THE BIG CONSTRAINT ON HOW
AGGRESSIVE THE PARTIES HAVE BEEN
ON DISTRICTING HAS BEEN
INCUMBEN